اتهم محمد حمدان دقلو قائد قوات الدعم
السريع في السودان قياده الجيش بالعمل وفق
توجيهات فلول النظام السابق وقال ان انهاء
الحرب ممكن خلال اثنتين وسبعين ساعه اذا
تغيرت تلك القياده
بالتزامن مع توقف مفاوضات جده بعد اعلان
الجيش عوده للتشاور وتاكيد واشنطن قلقها
بشان تقارير عن نقل مجموعه فابنر نظم دفاع
جوي للسودان
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذلك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات اولها على اي نحو يمكن
ان تنعكس تصريحات قائد الدعم السريع بشان
المفاوضات على مستقبل الحل السياسي في
السودان وما تاثير عوده وفد الجيش الى
البلاد على مسار مفاوضات جده ثم ما هي
العقبات التي قادت الى توقف مفاوضات جده
بين الجيش والدعم السريع وما فرص التوصل
الى حل بشانك ثم ما القضايا التي حسمها
المطافي المتفاوضون حتى الان ثم بعد ذلك
ما الذي يضيفه حديث واشنطن عن محاوله
فاجنر لادخال مضادات جويه الى السودان في
ظل صراع المصالح الراغم بين القوه الكبرى
في منطقه وسط وغرب افريقيا
[موسيقى]
في اول ظهور له بصوته والصوره منذ اندلاع
الحرب في السودان بين قواته والجيش قبل
اكثر من 100 يوم هاجم قائد قوه الدعم
السريع محمد حمدان قياده الجيش متهما
اياها بالعمل وفق توجيهات فلول النظام
السابق واكد ان وضع حد للحرب ممكن خلال
اثنتين وسبعين ساعه فقط في حال تغيير تلك
القياده
تصريحات وحميتي تزامنت مع استمرار
الاشتباكات بالاسلحه الثقيله بين الجيش
والدعم السريع في العاصمه السودانيه وتوقف
مفاوضات جده بين الجانبين والتي اكد الجيش
انه راغب في التوصل خلالها الى اتفاق فاعل
وعادل يوقف ما سماها العدائيات ويمهد
لمناقشه قضايا ما بعد الحرب الجيش اشار
ايضا الى ان وفد التفاوض عاد الى البلاد
الاربعاء للتشاور مع الاستعداد لمواصله
المباحثات اذا تم استئنافها بعد تذليل
المعوقات واوضح الجيش ان الخلاف قائم على
نقاط جوهريه مثل اخلاء من وصفهم
بالمتمردين لمنازل المواطنين والمرافق
العامه وهو ما ادى لعدم التوصل الى اتفاق
وقف القتال وعوده وفد التفاوض للخرطوم
من جانبها قوه الدعم السريع نفت من جانبها
ما ذكره الجيش بشان اسباب توقف مفاوضات
جده وقالت ان السبب في ذلك هو تعنت من
سمته وفد الانقلابيين واصراره غير المبرر
على فك الحصار عن قيادته في القياده
العامه وادخال الامدادات الغذائيه والوقود
والدواء لهم بحسب بيان الدعم السريع
[موسيقى]
لمناقشتي هذا الموضوع معنا من الدوحه
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي عادل الباز ومعنا
من الخرطوم الكاتب والمحلل السياسي حافظ
كبير اهلا بكما ضيفيه وابدا بضيف الخرطوبه
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي حافظ كبير وهذا
الظهور المفاجئ للسيد حميتي وحديثه عن
تصوره للحل كما ذكر خلال 72 ساعه في حال
ازاحه من وصفهم بقياده الانقلاب ومن ثم
تصور
للحل وبالتالي كيف فهمت هذا الظهور وما
صرح بسيد حميطي سيد حافظ
تحيه طيبه لك ولضيفك الكريم وللمشاهدين
انا اعتقد ان هذا التصريح هو تاكيد
لتصريحات سابقه وهي اتهامات الى قياده
الجيش بانها مسيطره عليها وانها غير قادره
على اتخاذ قرار بصوره مستقله للمضي قدما
في مساله السلام والمفاوضات وانها كل ما
تمضي نحو التوافق او نحو خفض تصعيد يعني
تتاثر بجنده سياسيه اخرى تجبرها على
مواصله الحرب والان ما يجري على ارض
الواقع يتطابق تماما مع اجنده فلول النظام
السابق وان تصريحات التي تقولها قياده
الجيش لا تجد طريقا الى الواقع سواء كان
ذلك في الهدن الموقعه او في التوجهات
العامه التصريح الوحيد الذي شذى وقال
بانهم يريدون الحرب هو التصريح الاخير
للجنرال ياسر العطا لكن ظلت قياده الجيش
دائما تقول بانها تستطيع ان تفاوض وان ان
تصل الى نهايه
نهايه العنف مع الدعم السريع عبر جده او
حتى عبر المنابر الاخرى لكنها عجزت عن
تنفيذ ذلك وبالتالي في هذه الحاله
الاعلاميه هل يصب في اتجاه ايجاد حل ام
يغلق الباب دون ذلك في حال وجود اي نيه
للتفاوض من قبل الطرف الاخر
الجيش عاد من جده مشترطا تذليل ما وصفه
بالعقبات للعوده لمحاوله ايجاد حل الازمه
في السودان
شكرا لك ولجيفك عبد القادر لا زال الفيديو
الذي بس اليوم هو موضع جدل بان كثير من
الناس ولم تطلع اياها موثوق بها تتحقق من
تاريخ هذا الفيديو ومتى تم تسجيله ولكن
ذلك ليس هو الامر المهم الامر المهم ما هي
الرساله الجديده التي قدمها حميدتي بهذا
الزهور انا اعتقد ان ليس هنالك اي رساله
جديده نفس الحديث عن البدروم يمكن انتقل
غليلا من يقتلهم الى انه يتفاوض معه يعني
دائما في ربك في الخطاب
بتقدموا بيقدمون المبردين
بتقدموا يعني هي تريد اتفاق مثلا في جده
وقعت عليه ان تخرج من بيوت المواطنين ان
تخرج من المغاره الحكوميه وان تقل
المستشفيات هذا ما وقعت عليه المليجيا
الان الشعب السوداني يطالب هذه المليشيا
لغاف الحرب بالخروج من هذه الاماكن ثم بعد
ذلك يتم التفاوض على مصيره وعلى ما يمكن
ان يكون مستقبله ولكن ما يقوله الدعم
السريع بان من هو محاصر الان ليس المدني
كما يدعي الجيش كما يقول الدعم السريع
ولكن القيادات هي المحاصره وبالتالي كيف
نفهم هذا المجال في مقابل ما يقوله الجيش
القيادات القيادات في فئه اماكننا ومنذ
اليوم الاول تعمل على تصفيه هذا التمر هذا
التمرد موجود في بيوت المواطنين هذا
التمرد موجود في المستشفيات هذا تمرد
موجود في الطرقات كيف يمكن ان يتحدث عن
ايقاف الحرب او مفاوضات وهو يحتل البيوت
المواطنين لا يستطيع الجيش وان اراد ان
يفاوض او ان يوقع اتفاق مع هذه الميليشيا
ان يفعل ذلك في في الحاله في حاله احتلال
بيوت المواطنين ما هي الحرب الذي يقصدها
السيد حمادي او ما هو السلام الذي يقصده
اذا احتلال بيوت المواطنين واحتلال
المغاره الحكوميه وترك جنوده والذي ينبههم
الان ان لا يغتصبوا ان لا يسبوا ان لا
يذهبوا المواطنين ان لا يحتلوا دورهم
ويتحدث عن انهم لا يفعلون ذلك
يعني
الجيش جيش المتمردين هذا هو عباره عن جيش
الحراميه لانه الموجوده امامنا الان هم
يغتصبون
سيد عادل يتم تكراره منذ بدايه الازمه
والازمه ما زالت مستمره وهنا اسال ضيفي
يعني لم يتوقف نعم وهنا اسال ضيفي السيد
حافظ ايضا عما يكرره الدعم السريع وما جاء
على في هذا الفيديو للسيد حميد يعني بغض
النظر عن الجدل المثار حول هذا الفيديو
وتوقيته ومتى ان كان حديثا او مسجلا من
قبل يتم تكرار نفس الكلام والمشهد على
حاله ومفاوضات متعثره في جده ما الذي
يجعلها متعثره وهل لك ان تشرح لنا النقاط
الجوهريه المختلف حولها سيد حافظ
هو يعني الخطاب مكرره لان الاحداث لم
تتجاوز هذا الخطاب حتى الان نحن يعني نجد
ان الجيش وحتى مؤيدوه يعني غارقون في نقطه
واحده في نقطه يعني
التداعيات التي خلقها الحرب الظروف
الانسانيه او الظروف المعلومه للناس جميعا
والحرب هي اكبر الانتهاكات اذا لم تتوقف
الحرب لا اعتقد ان القضايا الاخرى مثل
سلامه المواطنين وسلامه منازلهم وسلامه
كذلك المنشات العامه يمكن ان تتحقق دون
توقف الحرب يعني ونحن نعيش الان في ظل
القصف المدفعي والطائرات وكذلك اعتقد لا
يوجد عاقل يصدق انه يمكن تحقيق سلامه
الجميع في ظل هذا القصف لكن دعنا نذهب مره
اخرى الى التفاوض الجيش وفده ظل موجود
تقول القصف المدفعي والطائرات وكان قوات
الدعم السريع تحميل الظهور في هذه الحاله
الجميع يقصف انا اتحدث عن المناخ المناخ
فيه قصف مدفعي الدعم السري يقصف ايضا
بالمدافع وكذلك الجيش يقصد بالمدافع
الطائرات بالفعل هي للجيش لكن هذا هو
المناخ العام الذي خلقته الحرب وبالتالي
يعني هذه نقطه معلومه اي شخص يعرف الحرب
يعرف انه ليس بالامكان توفير بيئه امنه
وسليمه في منطقه حرب لكن دعنا نذهب الى
النقطه الجوهريه النقطه الجوهريه هو انك
اذا كنت جادا في ايقاف هذه الانتهاكات
كلها واوله والحرب ينبغي ان تذهب الى
المفاوضات وان يكون لديك اراده حقيقيه
ولذلك قدره ورغبه
في الوصول الى اتفاق هذا غير متوفر الان
عندما تتقدم المفاوضات
هل لك ان تشرح
والوفدان موجودان في جده
ويتفاوضان باختلاف تصريح كل طرف ان كانت
مباشره او غير مباشره اذا النيه في ايجاد
حل موجوده وبالتالي عن اي اطار تدفع له او
تدافع لاجله سيد حافظ
[موسيقى]
الاولى كانت من اجل حمايه المدنيين وتم
اتفاق معقول عليها واصبحت الخرطوم بنسبه
كبيره تحت سطره الدعم التالي ليس هناك
صراع ميداني مباشر في الخرطوم كانت هناك
يعني مشاكل في يسار المساعات الانسانيه
لكن حتى المساعدات الانسانيه التي جاءت
عبر بورسودان وصلت الى الجزيره تم نهبها
وبالتالي لم يستفيد المواطن من هذه
المساعدات الانسانيه وبالتالي هذه قضيه
اخرى الى الاتهامات المتبادله بين الطرفين
حتى عما ذكرته الان فيما يتعلق بوصول
المساعدات ومن يقوم بنهبها وهنا اسال ضيفي
السيد عادل الباز عن
ما الذي يعيق بشكل حقيقي التوصل الى اتفاق
ان كانت هناك نقاط جوهريه وهذا التفاوض كل
هذه المده هل هناك نقاط اقترب حولها
الطرفان ونقاط ما زالت عالقه ما هي هذه
النقاط بالتحديد سيد عادل لو تلاقي لنا
النقاط اصبحت واضحه وخارطه الطريق لحل
الازمه اصبحت واضحه ووقع عليها المتمردون
في جده
اخلاء المنازل اخلاء الدور الدور الحكوميه
اخلاء
المستشفيات من القوات المتمرده ووقف
الانتهاكات الجسيمه في حق
السودانيين هذه هي شروط وهذه الخريطه
الطريق وقع عليها
مرحله التنفيذ لم تنفذ المليشيا ما تم
الاتفاق عليه والان يريدون ان تتوقف الحرب
وكل هذه الشروط لم يتحقق واحد منها لن
يستطيع الجيش ان يفعل ذلك ولن يقبل الشعب
السوداني بان يوقع اتفاق سياسي او عسكري
بدون خروج هذه المليشيا المحتله لمنازله
واللي بتغتصب بنزائه لحد اليوم
في المواطنين بدون اي هدف ولا
هو يتحدث عن الدعم السريع يحتل يحتل
العاصمه 90 كله يعني كل الفيديوهات كل
التصريحات ان الدعم السريع تحت 90% اذا في
هنالك قوه تحتل 90% من العاصمه لماذا لا
تخرج بيانا الاول على السلطه وننتهي من
موضوع الحرب يعني هذه المليجي ظلت تكذب في
بياناتها ظلت في التصريحاته ظلت تكذب في
كل
الدعم السريع يقول بانه لا يسعى الى
السلطه
يجعل الى ماذا لماذا عملها قام بهذه الحرب
ليهدي الديمقراطيه الى السودانيين
السودانيين يحتاجون الديمقراطيه ان تاتي
بهذه الطريقه هم يقولون بان الحرب قد فرضت
عليه وانه لازاله من يصفونهم بفلوول
النظام واعاده السلطه المدنيين كما يقولون
دي الشماعه شايفين هو المجتمع الدولي يعني
يعزف فيها انه والله على هوى المجتمع
الدولي انه هون عايزين ديموقراطيهم
وعايزين الفلول مع زياد اسلام السياسي مع
زين كده ودي اجنده اصلا ما في خيال هذه
المليجيا ولا عندها طاقه فكريه ولا ثقافيه
ولا عندها تنظير حول ولا سمعنا اليوم حول
بعد ما هزمت وكسرت في الخرطوم اصبحت تتكلم
عن مشروع سياسي وتتكلم عن دوله 56 ودوله
الجلابه ودوله الداء تنظير سياسي ليس لهم
طاقه به ولا نعرف به ولا معرفه بتفاصيله
دي ملي
دائره تستلم السلطه بدعم خارجي طيب
وكذلك
الوقت يعود عامل الوقت وعامل الزمن يطرح
من جديد عن عامل الزمن فيما يتعلق بحسابات
الطرفين وجود البعد الخارجي ايضا يطرح عن
استمرار هذه الحرب في ميزان الطرفين مثلا
نائب المندوبه الامريكيه في مجلس الامن
الدولي روبرت وود اعرب عن قلقه المتزايد
عما سماها التي تفيد بان مجموعه فاجنر
نقلت انظمه الدفاع الجوي المحموله
عبر جمهوريه افريقيا الوسطى الى السودان
وهنا اسال ضيفي السيد حافظ كبير عن العامل
الخارجي هذا الخبر تحديدا في اطاله امد
الحرب وبالتالي زياده في تعقيد هذه الازمه
المعقده اصلا بتفاصيلها الداخليه
هو الذي يطيل امد الحرب هو الذي يستنفر
المواطنين للدخول في الحرب هو الذي يرفض
التفاوض هو الذي ايضا لا يريد القبول
بحقائق موضوعيه وحقائق الان يعيشها الناس
وينكرها الجميع ماذا عن سؤالي سيد حافظ
فيما يتعلق بهذا الخبر وتزويد وتحديد
القوات الدعم السريع بهذا النوع من
الاسلحه
هذا الخبر
يعني هذا الخبر يعني لا يمكن التاكد من
صحته الان لكن دعنا نفترض ان الحرب الان
نحن في الشهر الرابع لم يحتاج الدعم
السريع الى مثل هذه الاسلحه حتى يحقق
محققه خلال فتره الماضيه فلماذا يحتاج ما
تبقى من المعارك لا يتطلب اسلحه كبيره او
اسلحه نوعيه او يعني مضادات للطائرات هو
كان منتشرا وموجودا في كل هذه الاماكن دون
هذه الاسلحه وبالتالي لا اعتقد انه بحاجه
اليها الذي يحتاج الى اسلحه اكثر هو هو
الجيش او هو القيادات التي تريد استمرار
الحرب لكن دعنا نتحدث عن الحرب لا تتوقف
او تستمر بسبب الاسلحه او عدمها لكنها
تستمر بسبب الاراده او عجز الاراده عن
تحقيق السلام هناك اجنده يراد لها ان تفرض
على السودانيين بعد ان اسقطها السودانيين
بالسلميه واسقطها سياسيا في منابر النقاش
والقاعه التفاوض قاعات النقاش يراد لها
عبر السلاح والان هي هزمت ولا يريد حتى
ضيفك ان يعترف بهذه الحقيقه لكن هذا الوقت
قد ولى اوانه ان
البحث عن بدائل هو امر الان مطروح
القديم لا يمكن ان يستمر بعد ان هزم مرتين
مره عبر السياسه بثوره ومره الان عبر
السلاح وبالتالي لابد من الجلوس والنقاش
حول الجديد الذي يعني لم تتشكل الملامحه
حتى الان هو متاح هذا الامر لكن انه قران
حاله ان القران التي يعيشها البعض ومنهم
الضيفك الكريم لا تجدي هناك حقائق جديده
هناك اراء وافكار تطرح لاول مره ومسنوده
بقوه اجتماعيه وقوه عسكريه وبالتالي الان
في اجهزه التفاصيل
الجلوس والاستماع الى صوت العقل نعم من
قبيل ماذا هذه الافكار الجديده باختصار
الجديده هي مطالبتك
الاجنده الجديده هي مطالبه الاطراف وكذلك
المجتمعات المستفيده من التغيير الحقيقي
والكبير في هيكل السلطه وكذلك في وفي
برامج السلطان انها تطرح الان اجنده جديده
المستفيدون من التغيير اقصد بهم حتى القوه
الثوريه وكذلك القوه الحديثه بما فيهم
الذين يعرفون انفسهم بانهم ضمن هذه القوه
اطراف السلام وكذلك القوه التي يعني جاءت
بعد اسقاط النظام القديم النظام القديم
سقط سياسيا وكذلك سيد عادل يسقط عسكريا
ولا يتصور انه
حتى لو عاد الطرفان الى جده الى اي مدى
سيكون هذه العوده مثمره في ظل هذه الابعاد
الخارجيه وهنا اسال سؤال لمستردا الى ما
قراناه قبل قليل فيما يتعلق بتزويد وادخال
هذا النوع من الاسلحه من قبل فاجنر للساحه
السودانيه وكذلك اذا ما ربطنا ما يجري في
السودان بما يجري في المنطقه في الدول
المجاوره من هذه القاره الى اي مدى اي
جلوس للتفاوض سيكون مفيدا في ظل هذه
المعطيات الخارجيه
المختفيات الخارجيه الان هي
يعني تدعم كل كل
الذين يتحدثون بالخارج حول المبادرات
السلميه حول السلام ينسون ان هناك محطه
داخلي في السودان ولهذا المعطى الخارجي
انما حد التوصيف هذا المعطي هو تمرد على
السلطه لا احد سواء كان الاتحاد الافريقي
او المنظمه الايجارات تريد ان ان تقول ان
هذا الذي حدث تمرد ومن ثم
الدعوه الى انهاءه والدعوه الى الملكات
بايقاف بايقاف تمردها كما حصل الان في
النيجر الان قامت منظمه
الوحده الافريقيه وقامت قام العالم كله
تقريبا بوصف هذا انقلاب وتمر اما
المليشه المتمرده التي شنت حرب في الخرطوم
والتي باسم الديمقراطيه وباسم الحريه تغتل
في الناس
هذا هذا المجتمع لغه اجنده مع هذه مع هذه
المليشيا يريد ان يحقق بها ما عجز ان
يحققه خلال السنوات الماضيه باخداع
السودانيين لارادات خارجيه لنهب مواردهم
لتنفيذ حجم الاطراف المتناقضه دوليا سيد
عادل اذا مات طبعا ما اشرنا الى قلنا نقول
روسيا واذا ما قلنا راعي للمفاوضات
الولايات المتحده حتى هذه الاطراف اتفقت
هذه الاطراف
الارنب موضوع اخر له علاقه بمصالح
اقتصاديه متعلقه بتنقيب عن الذهب في
الحدود الحدود افريقيا الوسطى ولكن امريكا
لها مصالح تريد ان ان تمكن
للتيار علماني في السودان وهذا الصراع
الذي يتحدث عنه
حافظ كبير لم يسخر الا هذا الا الا قبل
قبل 15 ابريل او في 15 ابريل بعد سنه
الميليشيا الحرب ولكن هذه المليشيا قامت
بانقلاب مع الذين يتحدث عنهم الان في
البدروم
الباز الكاتب والمحلل السياسي شكرا لك
وكذلك الشكر لضيفي من الخرطوم الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي حافظ كبير
الى هنا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما
وراء الخبر الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]